so yesterday we talked about the covet
healthscape that
florida has become uh sort of almost
like as a feature of how
republican florida governor ron desantis
has handled the covet situation there
really uh flouting not flaunting
flouting
um all conventional wisdom and public
health
guidelines almost from the very
beginning of the pandemic now
we also have these other republicans who
they've been vaccinated
and if asked they'll say go and get
vaccinated but for the most part
throughout the pandemic
they've played the freedom and liberty
game and
mostly sucked up to president donald
trump and one such example is republican
senator from
representing the state of south carolina
lindsey graham lindsey graham has now
tested positive for covid19
and the timing of that positive test
suggests that because of a
boat ride he went on on senator joe
manchin's boat
um it may even be a sort of mini super
spreader event so let's first
look at what exactly is going on axios
reporting senator lindsey graham
tests positive for covid19
senator lindsay said yesterday he tested
positive despite being
vaccinated graham emphasized that the
mildness of his symptoms is due to being
vaccinated
if he had been unvaccinated his symptoms
would be far worse he said
that's his speculation but certainly
reasonable uh
thing to think it appears graham may
have exposed
a number of other senators to the virus
after he attended a weekend get-together
hosted by senator joe manchin democrat
from west virginia
on the latter's houseboat cnn reports
senator manchin is fully vaccinated in
following cdc guidelines for those
exposed to a coveted positive individual
senators mark kelly jackie rosen and
jackie rosen were also at the bipartisan
gathering
and are now following cdc guidelines for
persons exposed
senators catherine cortez masto john
thune and chris coons all of whom are
fully vaccinated also attended the boat
gathering
thune has already received his test
results and tested
negative for covid senate democrats have
gone back to holding virtual meetings
in light of the news of graham's
positive test so i haven't really
thought about lindsey graham for some
time but remember that
crazy situation where he refused to be
covered tested before a debate with i
believe it was jamie harrison who was
running against him for the senate
in 2020 and so they basically installed
a plastic shield
around lindsey graham uh sometimes
you'll see at big concerts
the drummer will have a plastic shield
so that
the drumming doesn't get picked up by
the microphones of other instruments and
people on stage
they did the equivalent but with lindsay
it was a coveted glass a plexi plexiglas
or plastic barrier
because he didn't want to be tested so
the point here is lindsey graham
has been relatively clear over the last
two weeks including now with his
positive test
i thanks to being vaccinated this is
probably less serious than it otherwise
would have been
go and get vaccinated it's important to
be vaccinated but
for basically the totality of 2020
he sucked up to trump and insisted trump
was doing a good job on covet despite
trump's job
job on kovid being one of the worst in
the world particularly for
what we would call one of the wealthier
countries
refused to be tested as part of his uh
freedom and all of this other stuff
and now he may have been involved in a
potential mini spreader event now again
the the senators on joe manchin's boat
saturday
were of course of course joe manchin
himself uh
mark kelly chris coons john thune i
mentioned jackie rosen
senator cantwell from washington and
senator cortez masto
from nevada and hopefully all of them
will uh
will test negative so there's been a
really interesting
you know at this point it's really
depressing actually that this is the way
it is
but signal and the absence of signal
both are being computed the same way by
the anti-maskers
and the anti-vaxxers when you
so you would think oh okay lindsay
tested positive
despite being vaccinated and his
symptoms are mild so that should lead
people to say
i should get vaccinated so that if i
test positive
my symptoms will be mild the problem
is that you'll have some people in his
base who will say oh
he was vaccinated and tested positive
therefore the vaccine doesn't work
that would be one incorrect
interpretation of what happened here and
they'll say
so i won't get vaccinated because it
didn't prevent lindsay
from testing positive uh the other one
is well he tested positive and it's mild
so therefore i don't have to go and get
vaccinated ignoring the reality that
there's a good chance we don't know for
sure
but there's a good chance that lindsay's
case is milder
and hopefully it remains milder because
he was vaccinated so
to you and me we would say this is the
this is the virtue of the vaccines
working lindsay is
i don't know he must be around between
65 and 70 i would get 67 something like
that
he is at a higher chance of a more
serious case
he says it's like a cold right now it's
mild
and he's vaccinated so this is the
virtue of getting vaccinated
other people will simply find in that
what they want either you don't need a
vaccine against something that's mild
or you don't need a vaccine that doesn't
work because he tested positive despite
being vaccinated so unfortunately it's
not going to be the big boon that you
and i might hope now
hopefully he recovers and then he
encourages people to get vaccinated and
at least
some of them listen and understand that
this change we've seen
from people like you know mitch
mcconnell claims he's been for the
vaccine
all along he got vaccinated he hasn't
been loudly for the vaccine all along
fox news you know everybody turning
pro-vaccine now
the reason in part we know that the
trump administration early didn't really
do that much about covid
is they saw it mostly affecting
democratic blue
cities new york city boston san
francisco
los angeles etc and so we know because
of the conversations between jared
kushner and trump
they just weren't worrying about it that
much because it was mostly affecting
their political
opponents adversaries enemies or
whatever whatever the case may be
now it is a very different situation now
the
number one coveted health scape in the
country is florida with often 20 or 30
percent of the entire country's cases
are happening in florida each day
hospitalizations record in florida over
10 000
highest of the entire pandemic covered
case rates
growing twice as quickly on average
in red counties that voted trump versus
blue counties that voted biden so
they realize now they are the ones at
risk of losing voters
because of that political reality that's
why they're changing their perspective
hopefully lindsay testing positive
phil valentine the radio host who was
anti-vac saying get vaccinated i'm now
on a ventilator
hopefully this gets people vaccinated
but unfortunately
i think for many of the anti-vaxxers
they will see this and say oh
this is more reason not to get
vaccinated
let's be honest most healthy snack bars
are not
exciting like my live streams and that's
why you should check out
our sponsor monk pack monk pack keto nut
and seed bars are sweet and delicious
soft and chewy with a big
satisfying crunch but each bar has just
one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and just 150
calories
so it's great for someone on a keto or
low carb diet or even if you just want
a tasty sweet snack without the sugar
monk pack keto nut and seed bars come in
great flavors like
sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea salt
or caramel you choose
and peanut butter dark chocolate i
always have a box of these ready to go
in my pantry
which is easy when you do the optional
monthly subscription which also saves
you 10
if you have a sweet tooth this is the
way to indulge without the guilt
whether it's for breakfast or in the car
or after a workout
go to monkpack.com the link is under
this video and you'll save 20
when you use code pacman at checkout